[Music]
hello their chastity here with your Star
Wars Holiday Gift Guide December isn't
just about the holidays anymore it's
also Star Wars time
robot a Star Wars story is out this
month and the hype is real for every
Star Wars fan in your life you're going
to need a gift luckily for you the force
is strong with this gift guide first up
is the famous Star Wars Episode 7
Chewbacca electronic mask
Chewbacca mom made this mask so popular
that it sold out at Kohl's after her
first video went viral back in May
put it on open your mouth and the mask
roars like everyone's favorite Wookiee
the wider you open it the louder it
roars it comes with two triple A
batteries get the Star Wars Episode
seven Chewbacca electronic mask for
$31.99 with Darth Vader appearing in
rogue one celebrate his return with
Disney's Darth Vader lightsaber a
lightsaber is essential for every Star
Wars fan and this is the best one you
can get on a budget become a Sith Lord
with this glowing red lightsaber
it features lights motion sensor sound
effects and battle clash lights and
sounds it's powered by three double A
batteries which are included Disney's
Darth Vader lightsaber is a great value
at 2995 for a gift that's both practical
and makes for a cool display check out
this tie fighter bluetooth speaker I
home special forces tie fighter
bluetooth speaker connects to most audio
devices connect your tablet or
smartphone via bluetooth or the aux line
and Jack and jam out to the Imperial
March you can also answer an end calls
via speakerphone the sound quality is
pretty good it's not top of the line but
it wins points for looking way cooler
than your average Bluetooth speaker get
a TIE fighter speaker for $49.99 Funko
pop figures are popular with kids and
adults alike add to someone specials
collection with the new line of road one
pop vinyls
here we have three of the row blonde
Funko pops our main character jyn erso
Donnie yen's character cheered my and
reprogrammed enforcer joyed k2s oh and
if you decide to complete the set there
are 18 total rogue one pops these pop
vinyls are all 3 and 3/4 inches tall and
retailed for $10.99 each this next gift
can talk to you or battle your household
pets this is legendary Jedi Master Yoda
this might be one of the most realistic
interactive Star Wars toys out there
legendary Yoda has voice recognition and
says over 115 phrases he comes to life
with lightsaber action and 360 degree
movement use Yoda to mess with your cats
or make him fight your other toys this
Yoda is 16 inches tall and sells for
$69.99 Yoda needs 6 C batteries to get
moving which are not included rogue ones
jyn erso also has her own nerf blaster
this is the nerf sergeant June or so
deluxe blast area comes with a six dart
clip and six glow-in-the-dark darts
prepare to rebell with this motorized
blaster that features laser blast sound
effects get one for $49.99 if you're
looking for a full sized helmet check
out the black serious shadow trooper
electronic helmet this detailed shadow
trooper helmet is wearable and features
voice effects looking for put it on
display it or add it to your helmet
collection if you do wear it visibility
is surprisingly decent this Black Series
helmet is an Amazon exclusive and sells
for $79.99 the voice effect microphone
requires three Triple A batteries which
are not included that's no moon it's a
Death Star mood light put this Death
Star on your desk or in your home it
glows in two different colors white or
red use it for dim mood lighting or as a
nightlight buy one for 2495 this light
can be powered by USB or with three
Triple A batteries which are not
included may the force be with you this
holiday shopping season
I'm chastity and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]